[Applause]
oh you're sleeping terrific are you
eating okay yes i don't know if they
give michelin stars to mental health
facilities but if they did
how's he doing really it's gonna take
some time he's been through a lot and
what about you oh i'm fine it's so right
people have been noticing you're acting
so funny you're distracted there's only
one way to fly
there's a guy i used to work with
someone you could talk to
what's your pet's name i i don't have a
pet no pet
that's a first come on back none of you
sit down stay
i've gotten a referral at new horizons
my husband is there i left a mental
health field 10 years ago to become a
vet mm-hmm that kind of weird i just
don't do this sort of thing anymore no
offense but you can kind of tell
don't
the bird obviously thought you were a
threat i am now
out of here
you familiar with stage three of the
grieving process
it's anger comes after that
depression great i can't wait
what is your plan i just need a minute
to figure out what happens next
you've been everything to everyone i
carried her for nine months so why are
you here
it's not about katie it's about tracking
you how do you restart
under
your skin
so you're a shrink but in a vet form
well
yes uh technically
some things are just out of our control
we're gonna move on and move up we're
gonna find an even better life than the
one we had
my wife wouldn't know how to quit and i
love her so much for it i want to not
quit with her yes
[Music]
starlings are different than other birds
they build the nest
together
they protect the nest together
just not meant to exist in the world
alone on her own
real subtle stuff larry i thought
[Music]